SHAKIL MEMON: Hi, and
welcome to "Building
an Internet-Scale Analytics
Platform on Google Cloud."
I'm Shakil Memon.
I'm a Customer Engineer
with Google Cloud.
Along with me I
have Nikhil Mishra,
Senior Director of Engineering
with Verizon Media.
Let's give you an insight
into today's presentation.
In this session,
we'll be presenting
complete end-to-end
solution architecture
for building an
internet-scale analytics
platform on Google Cloud
with over 100-plus petabytes
of data.
We will provide some
unique perspective
and behind-the-scenes
thinking, and some insight
on how the architecture has
evolved in its current form
over the years.
We will talk about
how Looker fits
into the end-to-end solution,
how Verizon Media is generating
actionable insights from the
wealth of data that they have
and that is coming
along with the websites
that they have in place,
how they are leveraging
other Google Cloud offerings
like Spanner, Pub/Sub, et
cetera, and how everything fits
together in the overall mix.
Let's walk you
through the agenda.
So we will start
with discussing some
of the challenges you face
when dealing with large scale
and large volumes of data.
We will discuss some of
the basic design principles
when you get started with a data
analytics or data warehousing
project.
We will walk you through one
of the reference architectures,
so give you some background.
Nikhil then will walk you
through the historical journey
and how the
architecture has evolved
from Hadoop, Hive
on Tez and Tableau
to the current-day architecture
of Hadoop plus Google Cloud.
Nikhil will also
walk you through
and talk about the various
Google Cloud offerings
that are being
used and what they
like about those offerings.
With that, let's take a
look at the Verizon Media
family of brands.
Verizon Media owns and operates
more than a dozen brands.
These are some of the most
visited and popular properties
and applications
on the internet.
When you're talking about a
rich set of popular media brands
like Yahoo Mail,
Yahoo News, AOL,
"Huffington Post," TechCrunch,
"Engadget," et cetera, that
are visited by millions
of users on a daily basis,
you need a robust infrastructure
to support those users
and meet their expectations from
a performance and reliability
perspective.
This gives you some insight
into what we are looking
at from a numbers perspective.
These Verizon Media
brands serve millions
of users who consume
large volumes of data,
reading or sending emails or
browsing through content that
is provided by the websites
and applications, which
in turn generates large volumes
of data that is being analyzed
and utilized for
providing recommendations
and serve as the data
analytics platform
for corporate utilization.
Now, let's walk you through
a little bit deep now,
to give you some further
insight into what Verizon Media
engineers are dealing
with on a daily basis.
There are a trillion-plus
events generated,
which leads to 100-plus
terabytes of data.
Now, Verizon Media is
always exploring ways
on how best to serve
their users' interest
and meet their demands.
And obviously, their users
expect fast and reliable
query performance.
And this is what have come
to expect over the years.
Their users are spread
all over the world,
and we need to provide
7 by 24 support
with traffic being
generated across the globe,
with users around the world who
are accessing these websites
and applications
from their laptops,
smartphones, and other devices
like iPads, tablets, and so
many other things
that are out there.
Now, let's take a
different aspect
and walk you through
the big data challenges.
Now, when you start out with
your data analytics project,
you will identify
the requirements,
and you will pick and choose
a few commercially available
products.
Now, in case of
Verizon Media, when
you're dealing with this
many number of users
and generating over a
terabyte-plus of data,
not any infrastructure
will work.
Now, the next thing
you do is once you
have some things in place as far
as the design and requirements
are concerned, is to pick and
choose a commercially available
database.
In the case of Verizon
Media, they cannot rely
on commercially
available databases,
as most of them fail to meet
Verizon Media's requirements.
Now, from a performance
perspective,
Verizon Media
users have expected
a certain interactive
response time,
which is hard to
maintain and sustain when
you're looking at this scale.
With that, let me hand
it over to Nikhil,
and he will walk you through
some of the basic design
principles.
NIKHIL MISHRA:
Thank you, Shakil.
Now, let us take this forward
and talk a little bit more
about how Verizon Media
approached this problem
and how we were able to
eventually solve it to take us
to the current architecture
where we have private cloud, as
well as Google Cloud into the
mix, to solve this problem.
Even if you are operating at a
large scale, a massive scale,
and you're tempted
to work around
your technical limitations
or take shortcuts in order
to solve your
problem, we all know
that if you follow certain good,
time-tested design principles,
we will improve our
chances of success.
You can think of the same theory
for analytics applications.
And the basic design principles
for analytics applications
don't change with scale.
They remain roughly the same.
For analytics systems,
you can think of it
as a collection of a fairly
decoupled, a loosely coupled
environment of these components,
these different systems,
subsystems, which take care
of their specific needs
with different architectural
characteristics.
So you can think of
analytics environment
as starting off with
a collection layer.
You always have a layer that
is responsible primarily
for collecting data from
disparate data sources
and making it available for
the rest of your enterprise
for analytics.
This collection environment
would be integrated with
and would be talking
to a storage layer that
is responsible for,
primarily, collecting
all this massive scale
data all in one place
and making it available for
the rest of the ecosystem.
The storage environment is not
meant for direct ad hoc access
or interactive analytics.
In our system, the primary
purpose of the storage layer
would be around
[INAUDIBLE] level storage,
cost-efficient storage of
pretty massive scale data,
redundant to failure.
We don't want data to be lost
at this layer between collection
and the stored layer,
single biggest priority,
architectural priority, if
you want to make a trade-off,
is the reliability.
You don't want any loss of data.
Because data, once lost
from one of these layers,
is very hard to bring back.
This is lost from the
source, and you don't
want to be in that situation.
Now, once the data is
available in the storage layer,
you always need a
processing layer
that is responsible for reading
data from this massive storage
layer and simplifying
it for further analysis.
The primary goal of this layer
is to apply business logic,
build a set of
attributes and metrics
which are easily
understood by your business
and allows them to
query this environment.
The compute requirement
in this layer
is slightly different from
what you would typically
expect for a querying compute
environment, which could also
form one of the
components of this system.
In this processing layer,
the compute requirement,
even though fairly elastic,
is highly predictable.
You know what volume of data
you would typically get over
a weekday, over a weekend.
You can also plan for
the compute requirements
for specific temporal
events or special holidays,
depending upon what your
business impacts are,
and you can plan for those.
So the compute requirement here
is limited to what you need
and what kind of business
processing you'd be doing.
This layer further
makes available--
once the data is ready,
it's made available
in a storage layer, which
is primarily the storage
layer that your users are going
to use for interactive querying
of their data.
The priority of
this storage layer
is interactive ad hoc analytics.
In this layer,
you'd want to have
characteristics that helps you
in ad hoc analytics at scale.
You'd want things like, for
example, columnar storage.
You know that in data
warehousing environment,
users are not going to
query all your data at once.
Even if your warehouse would
be 100 petabytes in size,
your queries would be typically
querying a few gigabytes
or a few terabytes of data.
They won't be creating entire
100 petabytes all the time.
So you want to make sure that
your storage architecture
in this layer supports those
kinds of ad hoc access, ad
hoc analysis, in a
very efficient manner.
You don't want to overload
your compute environment
in the querying layer
by querying data that
is not needed by your queries.
At the top of the pyramid, you
have your analytics compute.
The primary priority of
this compute environment
is to make the data from
the analytics storage
available for your users
in an interactive fashion.
Users can ask any queries they
want, any questions they want,
and they should be able
to query the massive data
warehouse using this compute
and be able to answer
their questions interactively.
And "interactivity" could
be in a few seconds.
It could also mean
a few minutes if you
are doing a pretty complex
and long-duration analysis.
The main goal of this compute
is around user response time,
and those are very
hard to predict.
You cannot say that your
business is going to ask x
number of questions
on a given day.
You cannot predict that
a user is going to--
that this specific
business process
is going to be more in
demand in a specific week.
It's very, very hard to predict
what kind of compute is needed.
So the primary goal
of this compute layer
is, essentially,
interactive analytics,
and you need a very, very
high level of elasticity
in this layer.
You may need
on-demand compute that
goes in multiple
terabytes in one day.
You could need a few
gigabytes on the other day.
So you want to be able to scale
up and scale down on demand.
And depending upon
the cost needs,
you may also want to reserve
some kind of compute capacity
if you know that you never
go below this compute need.
But more than that, you would
not want to be in a situation
where your users don't
have enough compute to do
their day-to-day functions.
Now, if you go and take
these design principles
and apply it in a public cloud
environment like Google Cloud,
you will see very
similar components
can be built using the
tools available for that.
On the collection
layers, you could either
have your partner storage
or your own internal storage
or file system,
from where you will
ship the data to Google Cloud.
You may have a streaming
environment where
you are piping in data, either
in your own queuing system,
or these are your IoT
devices or other devices that
are generating this
data, and push this data
through into the Google
Cloud environment using
one of the available choices.
You could directly
stream this data,
or you could use something
like Pub/Sub for sharing.
And on Pub/Sub, it's
a short-term storage.
You're not going to store
data here for years or months
that you would typically
store on a disk
or on a storage layer.
You'd be storing it here for
a few hours or a few weeks,
depending upon how
delayed processing you
expect in a streaming pipeline.
On the batch layer, you'd
be using a tried and tested
storage environment, and Google
Cloud storage would offer you
a pretty good redundancy.
This could be as
reliable as you could
get in terms of
availability, and you
could use this as your
primary storage layer
to bring in all your data.
On top of that, if you
want to do your processing,
you'd use a combination of
DataFlow and Cloud Composer.
DataFlow is-- as
you would know, it's
an implementation
of Apache Beam,
and it allows you to
very gracefully integrate
streaming pipeline as
well as batch pipeline,
and bring the data together,
and use a single code
to process the data in
both the environments,
in both the ecosystems.
You may also use
Spanner into the mix.
We use it pretty extensively.
We found it pretty useful
to do a very quick response
time, tenths of
milliseconds, hundredths
of millisecond response
time key value lookup
on a very large scale
dimension or attribute lookup.
And usually, in any
analytics environment,
you will have some
dimension which
has very large volume of data.
And you would need
those attributes
to be looked up in real time
as your data is being processed
to make it more meaningful.
Spanner plays a very
great role there,
and it's a fantastic
transactional database
which can handle a
massive scale of data.
And you will want to
use it when you're
doing your stream processing.
As you move on, you
would read this data
from the storage layer using
the processing environment
and put it into an analytics
database like BigQuery, which
supports all the
typical characteristics
of large-scale analytics
querying database
that we talked about.
It has columnar storage, and
it has encrypted at rest.
Now you be able
to take advantage
of columnar compression.
The data is laid out in
highly optimal fashion
and continuously keeps
optimizing itself on its own
without you having
to do anything.
And once you have your
data stored in here,
you could use the query
slots to query this data.
You'd be using Looker as a
BI tool to query your data.
You could use other
tools, as well.
Our preference has been Looker.
It's worked great for us.
And you could also
bring in a Google
Sheet or other environment into
the mix to analyze your data.
But essentially,
the key aspect here
is the elastic compute
slots that you need
and the kind of ad hoc analysis
capability you will get
using a BI tool like Looker.
As we move on, the architecture
that we started off with
was quite different.
We were pretty much on-prem,
and with Yahoo's background
with Hadoop and the
kind of contributions
it has made to Hadoop,
it was pretty easy
for us to spin up a
large-scale cluster
to handle huge volumes of data.
The collection layer,
the collect layer, for us
was essentially a
set of beacon servers
that would instrument the
activities that were happening
on different pages, capture
the signals that we would need
for various use
cases, and funnel it
into our private
cloud environment.
The storage for
real-time was Kafka,
and we would use it
for temporary storage
until the data is consumed
by downstream pipeline
that we use Storm for.
And the batch layer
would take this data
and put it in the Hadoop
environment as DFS storage.
This data would then
be further processed
using, again, the Hadoop
environment and Storm, which
was essentially a sister
environment for, in our case,
both clusters were
managed using YARN,
which, again, is a resource
scheduler that you'd have on--
typically identified
with Hadoop.
And we would use that compute
to do all kind of processing
we need on our
underlying data set
and bring it into
our database layer.
We use two databases on on-prem.
For streaming, we
used Druid, which
was pretty good at
indexing large-scale data
and making it available in
a very short span of time,
within seconds, when I
wanted it to do stuff,
to do analytics on.
For the batch layer,
for historical analysis,
we used Hive on Tez
with ORC storage,
which, again, is a columnar
storage, built for or designed
for ad hoc analytics.
And we made this
available via a BI layer.
At that point in time,
we chose Tableau.
And the reason for
choosing Tableau
was primarily driven
by the limitations
that we had with Hive
on interactive response.
We knew that Hive on
Tez would perform better
for a large number of
queries, but still could not
give sub-second response time.
It was not meant or
designed for that purpose.
So we plugged in that hole using
Tableau's Data Engine, which
would allow us to extract a
significant volume of data
and cache it into
the BI layer and make
it available for
users on Tableau
to do ad hoc analysis
on dashboard.
For interactive analytics,
or for ad hoc analysis,
without pre-built dashboards
or pre-built cubes,
we hooked up Looker
on top of Hive
and made it available for our
users to do ad hoc analysis.
We had a custom web
application layer as well,
which was querying
Druid and which
would be used for content
analytics, [INAUDIBLE]
analytics by [INAUDIBLE].
We handed this
data to our users,
and we started monitoring
our performance
and how our users respond
to this architecture.
We soon learned that most
of the queries that we
were hitting for ad hoc
analysis via Looker to Hive
were failing out.
A pretty significant
percentage of them
were failing, either due
to resource constraints,
or due to an integration
issue, or how
the query's been kicked off.
And the queries that completed,
even those, more than half
of them completed in more than
two minutes or three minutes
time.
It was not an
interactive response time
that we needed or wanted
to give to our users.
So we were on this environment
for a few weeks, few months,
and we soon learned that this
was not going to work out.
This was not going to
be something that we
would be able to carry forward.
We started exploring
alternatives.
And around the time,
we specifically
focused on the querying compute
layer, the [INAUDIBLE] querying
layer.
The rest of the system
was working all right.
And as we started
exploring, what
caught our attention was
a Dremel white paper that
was released by
Google just a little
while before we were
doing this analysis.
The focus of Dremel
was, essentially,
to work around the
limitations on MapReduce
in terms of interactive
response time.
When MapReduce produce was built
to improve large-scale batch
processing, Dremel was
built to bridge the gap--
still have the goodness of
processing large-scale data,
but reduce this response
time that a user would
get to [INAUDIBLE] their data.
We're also caught
our attention were
some of the statistics
in the white paper.
If you look at it,
there are tables
that were used with
pretty large-scale volume.
We had one trillion
plus row table,
which is very similar to the
environments we had internally.
We had tables with 1200
plus columns, which
is, again, something that
we had and we operated on.
The next thing that
caught our attention
was the scalability
and interactivity.
If you can see,
the interactivity,
most of the queries
that were tested out
seemed to be completed
within 10 seconds.
Now, that's within
the ballpark of what
we were looking for in
terms of interactivity
on our data scale.
And on the scalability
part, you can
see that it's fairly
linearly scalable.
As you added more
nodes, you'd be
able to increase your
performance and interactivity
of your [? query. ?]
We also came across a
pretty nice analysis
done by another third
party company, AtScale,
which did an
analysis and made it
available for the public
to see all the options that
are available for
large-scale data analysis,
and see the concurrency
and response
time of different solutions.
As you can see, most of
these alternate solutions
had major issues when
concurrency went up
beyond a certain threshold.
The degradation of
query performance
was not proportional to
the number of queries being
submitted up to that point.
It was unusually slow beyond
a certain point, which
is something that we observed
in our environment as well,
and it was reflective of
the limitations of what
we are facing in a
MapReduce or Tez environment
that we had in-house.
For BigQuery, however, you can
see the concurrency response
time seemed to be pretty flat.
As more queries came
in, even though there
was a query degradation,
it was pretty graceful,
pretty proportional,
not drastic as you
would see in some of these
other alternate databases.
So we decided to give it a shot.
We relooked at our architecture.
We obviously did not
need the computer layer
that we had for querying,
and we wanted to replace it
with Google Cloud.
We also wanted to have a
relook at our BI architecture,
or the BI tool
that we were using
as part of this rearchitecture
[? plan ?] that we had.
Well, one of the
first things that we
had to look at as we
were moving massive scale
data between our data
centers to Google Cloud
was to see, what
are the bandwidth
limitations that we had?
Working with our
networking team,
we realized that the 10 gigabit
network capacity that we had
may not suffice for our needs.
As we put in some
more numbers, we
learned that on an
average, what would
we need should be OK with
the bandwidth we had,
but this would pretty much
take away most of the capacity
that we had within the
data center in terms
of network bandwidth.
So keeping in mind
other workloads
from within the company that
may need something like this,
we decided to upgrade
the bandwidth.
We also learned that our overall
peak requirements would be
somewhere around 70 gigabits.
So should we go ahead
and upgrade straightaway
to 70 or more than that?
Or should we stagger it?
So we decided to stagger it
and monitor the performance
as we go forward and
see the utilization.
And based on that,
if there was a need,
we would go ahead and
upgrade [INAUDIBLE]..
So we worked with
the Google team.
We established a direct peering
connection between the two data
centers and upgraded the
bandwidth to 30 gigabits
capacity.
With that, we brought in
BigQuery into the mix.
And the cool thing about
BigQuery is the network.
That's one of the first
things that we noticed,
that the compute and the storage
communicated with each other
and the combined
network bandwidth
capacity of a petabyte, which is
their implementation of Jupiter
network, which plays a big role
in how the platform performs
and the kind of response
time we are able to get, even
at such a large scale.
We moved our data
in there, and as we
started querying this
data, we realized
that we would be able to now
move our ad hoc analysis layer
and make it the primary source
for not only ad hoc analysis,
but [INAUDIBLE] needs as well.
Looker was a tool of preference
for us for multiple reasons,
but a few key
aspects that appeal
to us were its semantic
layer and its ability
to handle a lot of
warehousing needs,
like aggregate awareness,
dynamic building
of derived tables, which are
essentially what you would call
[INAUDIBLE] in traditional
environment, and you you
would be able to, even, persist
them within the same database.
It was pretty cool
features that we had.
But one of the most
appealing things
that we liked about Looker
was the semantic layer.
As any of you who has
operated warehouse at scale,
you know that documenting
your data warehouse
at such a massive scale where
you have thousands of columns
is a big challenge.
It's not easy to keep
the document up to date
all the time.
Now, if you come
across a tool that
lets you define something
like a Looker, [INAUDIBLE]
Looker does, and allows
you to define your metrics
and dimension in the same place
and use the same definition
to generate the
data dictionary, I
think that's a
perfect documentation
that anybody would need for
their warehousing environment.
And with Looker, we
were able to get that.
What also helps is
that when you have
such large-scale attributes
and metric combinations,
you end up creating various
combinations of aggregates.
In a typical BI tool, for
every table that you create,
you're going to
redefine or re-implement
the definitions that you had to
those attributes and metrics.
And there is hardly any
scope to reuse a definition.
Every time there
is a change, you
end up changing multiple
files and data sources
in order to bring consistency.
Usually, you are not
able to, and you end up
creating inconsistent
definition or dictionary
for your users, which ends up
creating a lot of confusion.
So with Looker, we were able
to get a [INAUDIBLE] data
dictionary whenever
a definition changes.
We are also able to
reuse these definitions,
and we do not have to define
a same attribute again
for a different attribute.
We can simply reuse
the same definition.
We also leveraged
this semantic layer
using Looker's RESTful API
and made those definitions
available to our web
application layer, which did not
have to define its own complex
API layer with all the business
logic contained.
All the business logic stayed
in a unified semantic layer
within Looker and was reused by
the web application layer, as
well as all the rules that were
accessing the data directly
using API or via the
[? lookup ?] layer.
We also brought in Google
Sheets into the mix,
and Google Console
was obviously there.
And Google Sheet proved
to be a super hit
within our in-house community.
And it would be very
similar in most places.
Google Sheet is a pretty
commonly-used and pretty
popular tool that
most of the analysts
like to use to communicate
their data storage.
And with an ability to embed
the SQL within the sheet
and be able to refresh
the sheet on demand,
this is a pretty powerful
feature, and something
that we saw in use--
as we rolled it out, we
saw that It was probably
the most widely-used
interface of Looker
by all of our users, something
that everybody has liked a lot.
The other way integration of
Google Sheet and BigQuery,
which I call as more of a
transactional integration,
where you are able to enter new
rules within the Google Sheet,
I'm able to query directly
without any [INAUDIBLE]
from within BigQuery, while
Looker, while Google Sheet
itself, again, you'll be
able to do that, which saves
a lot of time in doing
quick prototypes,
or having a [? cleansed ?]
dimension lookup logic,
or anything that you want may
want make available on demand
for your users via
a BI layer, you
should be able to do it using a
Google Sheet instead of having
to bring in a database
and build a custom web
application to handle
transaction processing.
We started monitoring
our usage, and we
saw that the users were
pretty soon querying
more than an exabyte
of data per month.
And when we looked
at the performance,
it seemed like most of the
queries were succeeding.
And the ones that were
succeeding, the bulk of them
completed in a very good
interactive response time.
The bulk of them
were at 10 seconds.
We saw that 30 seconds was
a typical response time
that people would get for
complex queries involving
large volumes of data.
This was a pretty acceptable
concurrent interactive response
time that we'd expect
from our users,
and it's led to a set
of very happy user base.
But as we started looking
at rolling this out
and started investing
more and more in capacity
on the environment,
we also had questions
around the cost of
ownership or the total cost
that we are putting
into this environment.
And cost is not the
same for everybody.
If you talk to an IT team,
the understanding of cost
would be very
different from what
the business team would mean.
So we decided to come
up with a currency
where you would be
able to put a dollar
value to the kind of benefits
you get when you have
a highly capable
analytics querying
layer available to your users.
So we picked up
some query patterns.
This is an example
query that you see.
And you can see the difference
in the query response
time between our earlier
environment versus what
you see with BigQuery today.
If you translate it to
the millions of queries
that were being executed
on that environment,
that's tens of
millions of dollars
saved in just
productivity improvement
across the environment.
In order to work on the
limitations of interactivity,
you would either
hire more people,
or you'd have to live
with the productivity loss
that your analysts or that your
data users are going to suffer.
And when you start looking at
it and you go and take a look
at your IT team,
their response time
would usually-- even though
they would say that it's usually
the cheaper hardware which,
obviously, is their lower
cost of ownership,
their business
would go and share
those numbers with them
and give a complete picture.
And that, essentially,
gives a common currency
that both the teams
and organization
could talk to and explain
the cost of ownership
for rolling out
such an environment.
This is a pretty
common discussion
that you would see
most of the time
when you bring in a change,
migrate from on-prem
to on-cloud.
And as you brought
in and documented
all these various queries,
and their response time,
and what people are able
to do with the availability
of this environment,
it centers a lot
of these conversations around
the cost of rolling out
this feature.
The usage numbers
went up dramatically.
As we have said
this multiple times,
we've seen a peak of 6 exabyte
queries across a month.
A million queries are the norm.
We're also seeing queries going
as high as 20 million-plus
as more and more system
queries are brought in,
and [INAUDIBLE] different
events and different phases
in the enterprise with different
demands on the analysis data
set, we've seen a pretty
large volume of data going on.
We have about 2,000 users
using this on a daily basis.
This is increasing
every other month,
and more and more users
have bee onboarded.
And we've been able to handle
new use cases and new users
pretty effectively
without much of a change
in our architecture.
So to summarize what has
made BigQuery so popular
and what has allowed us to have
such a wide adoption, if we are
to call out certain features
which we really like
and which we believe has
played a huge role in how this
has been adopted and has worked
over the past many years,
the biggest thing we
as an engineering team
have gained out of this is we
no more focus on infrastructure.
BigQuery has been
pretty much NoOp for us.
It's serverless,
it's self-tuning.
We don't spend as much time
on sizing up the cluster,
sizing up of the database,
defining indexes, or trying
to tune the queries
that users are filing.
If you look at the isolations
between compute and storage,
that also extends
between the compute
that is used in loading
the data and compute that
is used in querying
the data, which
makes a huge difference on
how we are able to manage
and commit to our SLA for
users for data availability,
and how we are able to
manage our SLA in terms
of user response time to
queries, at high concurrency
or otherwise.
And concurrency,
again, it's just
a fact of how it
has been architected
or how the isolation works.
We have not been able to
see any kind of issues
with high concurrent query
response time for our users.
The degradation is
usually graceful.
Most of the queries will
have slight degradation.
Most of the end users
won't even notice it.
We haven't had a scenario
where a runaway query has
been able to bring the
cluster almost to its knees.
We haven't seen that.
We've seen that before,
and a lot of you
might be facing it in
different environments
that you are using.
BigQuery has been interactive
even at such a high usage,
and it's been working pretty
well even when the users are
querying months worth of
data, or many, many months,
or even, in some cases,
years worth of data.
We have been able to manage
that pretty effectively.
Security has been a key aspect.
It's something that
we focus on a lot,
since there's a lot
of data that's there
that we don't want this to be--
that could be misused or abused.
We make very, very heavy use of
Google's column-level security.
The data is
encrypted, of course,
so that obviously helps.
But we do use custom roles,
column-level security,
and role-level security
in our environment.
We set up pretty extensive
monitoring of our data set.
Google provides a
pretty good and easy way
to set up your DTS, which is
Data Transfer Service, that
allows you to monitor
all your actions
and make it available
for your users
and for yourselves
to go and create.
So you can go and pump
in this data in BigQuery
and build dashboards and
reports on top of it.
And depending on what
you want to monitor,
you can just expose it to
different sets of uses.
DMLs have been a
lifesaver for us.
And this is typically for a
data warehousing environment
where you may want to restate
the data for various reasons.
In absence of efficient
DML, you end up
reprocessing the entire
data on your own,
which is not a good usage
of your compute capacity.
If you have a good DML, whether
it's a [INAUDIBLE] statement
or update, most of
the time, you'll
be able to very quickly
restate the data without having
to go and reprocess
your entire data
and run your entire [INAUDIBLE].
A two-way Google
Sheet integration
has been [INAUDIBLE] talked
about how our analyst community
has used Google Sheet
integration with BigQuery
pretty effectively.
On the editing side, you have
used Google Sheet integration
the other way around,
where we insert data
into Google Sheet
whenever there is
a change in a label, for
example, of an attribute,
or if you want to bring in
some small lookup dimension
that the users want
to query using Looker.
We just create a
sheet, we hook it up
to BigQuery [INAUDIBLE]
table and make
it available for users.
Compare this to a
traditional environment
where you would need a separate
database, a UI layer to insert
those data, an ETL layer to then
bring it back to an [INAUDIBLE]
database-- in this
case, BigQuery--
and then make it available
via a Looker layer.
All those intermediate steps
could be easily eliminated
by simple [INAUDIBLE],,
which, for me, has been
a big usage within the team.
Spanner is another tool that
we use pretty extensively
on our streaming pipeline.
Spanner can handle
pretty large-scale data.
The way to see this,
like SQL on BigTable,
or XBase, if you're
familiar with it.
And it allows you to do a quick
lookup on a very large scale
data.
We have dimensions
with billions of roles.
And in our streaming
processing, we
would need those attributes
to be looked up to annotate
our events with a ledger.
And Spanner allows us to that.
BQML has been another
great addition
to BigQuery's offerings.
Just a few years ago, this
was something unthinkable.
You could not imagine
doing machine learning
or advanced analysis
just with a click
of a button on either Looker or
through a simple SQL interface.
BigQuery allows us to do that.
Our users have been using it
to do pretty sophisticated
analysis from within
their Looker windows
or from within
their Google Sheet
and are able to predict and
classify a lot of things
without involving any data
engineer or data scientist.
They're able to do it completely
on the fly, which is something
for which they would have to
write a lot of code earlier,
they can handle using SQL
within the same environment.
All these features have
helped us pretty extensively,
and things that have
allowed us to build
a pretty large
internet-scale data
warehouse with 100-plus
petabytes of data and the user
status that you've seen.
And it's been working well, and
the capabilities that you're
seeing here, there are many
more that I could talk about,
but these are the key
stuff that come to my mind.
It's been a great
experience for us so far,
and because it was really
fun to share our learnings
and what we have
learned using BigQuery
and how our experience has
been over the past four or five
years using BigQuery.
And hopefully, this
helps some of you
to take some of the
[INAUDIBLE] learnings or some
of the good practices
that you learned here,
and apply it in your
own environment,
and maybe exchange notes
on what you have learned,
and if there is
anything that you
would like to know more about.
Thank you.